anna is with us anna is in right button
she is in texas hi Anna how are you sir
oh my god how can we help okay I look
I'm a Christian for you Christie I'm a
mom and a hairstylist and I just want
you I wanted to ask you how high the
probability of me becoming maybe like a
youtube star or an Instagram start
making my own YouTube channel with
hairstyling okay so first I want to ask
you Anna
when you say star what do you mean by
that what do you want to be a star no or
maybe like maybe making money out of you
know yeah okay sure so I think that's
great I think when you're looking at
YouTube as the platform specifically
I'll speak to that since that's what you
asked about you just need to think about
exactly what problem you're solving for
your customers in the world of YouTube
what problem are you solving for your
viewers like why should they tune in
because all day every day your customer
your viewer is that their brain is wired
for one question which is what's in it
for me why do I care so your content on
your YouTube channel should speak to
that so so what are you doing through
your YouTube channel are you showing
them how to do update updos on your own
without paying expensive prices are you
showing them how to do a blowout in less
than five minutes are you showing them
how to cut their husband's hair when
they're at home and their husbands grow
in an afro because James these are
things I'm signing up has no idea I'm
talking about right now just to do
tutorials for wives that need to cut
their husband's hair because their
husbands grow in an afro and he's still
trying to do zoom calls Matt writes
hairs very thick and he won't let me cut
it tell this was a personal issue with
you he may be smart you may not be one
of your skills it's valid I've never
done it before but I'd like your husband
so you just need to think about what
what value are you offering through this
YouTube channel
people want to tune in because it's
going to help them in some way and so
thinking that through you know and then
just keep in mind like people making
money on YouTube there needs to long
gameplay you're not just going to put up
one video and you start getting checks
in the mail so this is kind of like a
blog where you your eyeballs are what
you charge for there's several different
ways to do it or you could have it could
be a marketing funnel to sell your
classes or something else if you're
going to use that venue you need to
understand your customer base is young
they're not they're not 60 year old
women okay so they're in their 20s with
with exceptions but that's gonna be your
largest our youngest of viewer between
all the different ways we broadcast is
our YouTube viewer which we love by the
way we're excited about that
but I get more 22 year olds there than I
do anywhere else you know in terms of
and here's the reason the number one
search engine in the world is Google
when someone wants to search how to cut
their husband's hair at home it's Google
the number two search engine is YouTube
unless you're 34 years old or under and
then the number one search engine is
YouTube and so while a lot of people
think of YouTube as cats chasing lasers
or funny stuff or whatever it is a huge
how-to community because it's the search
engine and so how old are you Anna
I'm 28 okay when you get ready to search
something is what I'm saying true when
you if you said okay I need to know how
to chop onions without crying would you
google it or youtube it okay yeah and I
would probably just google it and then I
would have to remember I'm 60 that oh
yeah they do that on YouTube too or
maybe I need a video that I'm gonna end
up from Google being handed off into
YouTube that way but that that's what
you need to think of is your probably
your customer and so if it's funny to
you and your husband it's probably gonna
be funny to your viewer if it's in
directive to you and your husband or
poignant or sad or makes you tear up or
make sure throat gets height because
it's a touching story for you and your
husband it's probably is for your viewer
the good news is if you're on your if
you if you are your own focus group in
marketing it makes life a lot easier
because you know how the customer thinks
because they're you and so that that's
why Christy could you know immediately
go to she's in the same age group
immediately go to cutting my own
husband's afro yeah that's hilarious one
other piece of encouragement I would
give you an ax is it's really tempting
in the social media world where you have
these immediate metrics of whether or
not people like me if I'm popular to
only look at what your idea of success
is like I want two hundred thousand
viewers two hundred thousand subscribers
you don't you're never gonna get there
if you don't focus on the two and then
the twenty and then the two hundred so
take care of your base take care of the
followers you have today I love how the
Bible talks about this do not despise
these small beginnings be faithful with
what you've been given right now so you
will start small everyone starts
somewhere and you will too but be
faithful there and when you're faithful
you will see it naturally grow don't
just always be focused on on the big
numbers be focused on Heath got right
now yeah don't don't hesitate to be
entertaining and fun funny and you know
and give our people a reason because if
it's simply just executing the drill
it's not gonna get a ton of views unless
you're the only person knows outdo that
thing on the planet and then it'll get a
lot of views and of course there's two
places to make money on YouTube one is
if your have enough views they send you
a check because you're generating ad
revenue for them and the second thing is
if you have products and/or services or
whatever there are inserted into the
actual body of the YouTube video then
they go oh she has a book on this oh she
has a whole class on this or whatever
and then you can upsell so to speak out
of the free YouTube view into something
else and that'll get you going there
interesting question thanks for calling
in